[Music]
hey you guys oh look pokey's joining us
on the show she's down there messing
with me she just came yeah she just came
in because she's like oh it's time for
us to do the show she was sleeping
that's all she ever does she doesn't
meow a lot she just makes that makes
that noise all the time
she's always doing that yeah aren't you
pokey she's like that's right why are
you talking about me like that she knows
we're talking about her yeah of course
she does she's like that's right i'm the
star i'm the star but uh yeah
fourth row down what the heck is going
on in this movie yeah so uh
i was like this is a french porn movie
isn't it
i was waiting for the girls to go yeah
he kept saying it's like the opening one
of the opening scenes of this movie
where like all the school girls are
coming down to the the stairs and
they're just he's like is this going to
turn into a french porn movie he's
probably like i hope i hope
no it's not a french porn movie i like
seeing these movies before
is emmanuel gonna be in this no um yeah
this is picnic at hanging rock this came
out in 1975 directed by peter weir this
is actually an australian film
one of the first movies that kind of
like introduced the australian new wave
to the rest of the world
um
honestly this is i i saw this movie like
a really long time ago and i remember
really really digging it like it's it
has like
it's just hard to explain it has this
really like creepy
unsettling eerie kind of vibe to it i
will say if you're not into like
ambiguous horror then you you probably
won't like it because you'll be like
what the [ __ ] i don't and even at the
time i think like some
uh audiences and some even though this
did actually do very well
uh at the box office and actually
critically as well but there were some
critics and some audiences are like what
the [ __ ] like you never figure out what
happened and stuff like that which i
will kind of get into because
um
you do actually kind of figure out
or you do actually kind of like learn
what happens in the
not in the original novel but in
the original
end chapter of the original novel which
was not published until later workman's
here i might have to go let him in oh
okay take care of this you can handle
this i don't really have much to say
about this movie but but i'm gonna have
to direct him well okay we'll come back
when you can come back
uh yeah okay so i didn't i forgot that
he was like uh coming by today so uh
yeah cheryl said i just saw this so yeah
so i hadn't seen it for a really long
time so i was really looking forward to
re-watching it and because somebody
reminded me that it was uh took place on
valentine's day i was like oh we should
do it for
uh right around valentine's day even
though that was yesterday but whatever
so the thing about this
is that i mean if you don't know if
you've never seen this story and like i
said i'm gonna spoil it so because it's
old
um
so you have like a group of english
school girls
in
1900
and they're actually at this school like
uh apple yard college which i guess like
some kind of private finishing school or
something of that nature
uh and it's in australia
and
one day these uh valentine's day in 1900
all of these schoolgirls or most of them
go on an outing
to a place called hanging rock which is
a real place in australia it's in
victoria i believe and it used to be
like it's a
it used to be a volcano i don't think
it's an active volcano anymore but so
it's like a weird like geological
formation
so they go on this picnic
and subsequently a handful of them even
though they're not supposed to they go
up and explore the rock
and the whole thing is just very like
weird and ambiguous and they disappear
and
they are never
found uh cheryl said it doesn't seem
like a tom movie anyways yeah it's
definitely it's definitely not
camp guy said dennis raider is coming to
install a burglar alarm yeah probably i
don't know if he has to come inside
because i thought he was just doing
landscaping today but then tom said
something about well he might have to
measure windows and i was like yeah but
if he's doing landscaping wouldn't he be
measuring the windows from the outside
and not have to come in and measure them
from the inside i mean they're the same
size inside as outside i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on
i don't know he just he set all that up
and i didn't know it was happening but
i'm pretty sure it's the landscaper but
he's like telling him what to do
so so yeah so essentially um you know
don't get
don't think that there's going to be a
resolution of the mystery you never find
out like one of the girls is found later
uh unharmed
but she doesn't remember what happens
oh okay
yeah he's good he's a good he's good
didn't he have to measure windows but he
can do that from the out he does that
from outside right now he's gonna do it
from the inside but uh he said when the
show's over
oh god get him he'll do it he doesn't
need me or anything he's got his orders
i didn't know if he needed help moving
that thing oh okay go planner all right
but he does
yeah somebody said uh somebody said that
uh dennis rader was coming to install a
burglar
[Laughter]
yeah so so don't go into this thinking
that you're gonna figure out what
happens at the end of the mystery
because you don't you never do find out
one of the girls
is found later but she doesn't remember
what happens
so
what the [ __ ] is going on okay so this
was based on a novel that came out in
1967 uh that was written by joan lindsay
now i haven't read the novel but
i did read a plot synopsis of it and
then i read something about it on
wikipedia
now when this book came out this is very
interesting because it's almost kind of
like you know how everybody thinks like
meta fiction and like found footage and
that kind of [ __ ] is kind of like a new
thing not really because this book
she uses
real locations like hanging rock which
as i said is a real location in
australia
and
she
frames this story as though it's
something that really happened like this
was an actual mystery all these english
school girls went out to this uh outing
and some of them disappeared and were
never found and we never figured out
what happened to them and so she sets it
up like it's a real thing but it's a
fictional story but she's trying to
portray it as though this is almost kind
of like not necessarily like a true
crime type of thing but like it really
happened
now interestingly
she wrote
a final chapter of the book
in which
you kind of figure like in which it kind
of explains what happens a little bit
now this is hinted at in the movie
because if you watch the movie there's a
lot of weird stuff you you suspect that
something probably supernatural is going
on because when the schoolgirls get to
the site there's something kind of like
otherworldly about it like there's these
weird like she's
she knocked that over that orange thing
it's just like a little pumpkin it's
fine okay she tried to eat it
oh well don't let her eat it
i mean i don't it's just like a little
foam
pumpkin yeah she thought that was food
oh yeah please don't eat
that she's like screw it i'll make it
food yeah yeah
i'll make anything that's that's too big
for her to eat i think i would she was
chewing on it oh i don't want her to
choke on it yeah
uh but yeah so
so you suspect that there's something a
little weird going on because there's
like a weird like whoa kind of noise and
a couple of the characters mentioned
that their watches have all stopped at
12 o'clock
and also one of the teachers miss mccraw
who is actually one of the ones that
also disappears later like along with
the school girls
um she's
they they kind of have this conversation
on the way there about
um
time and about so there's all of this
weird [ __ ] about time and everything so
they do kind of like hint
that whatever
force is going on at this
rock is kind of like almost kind of like
a portal or a vortex
or some kind of thing where
people can just be like sucked through
and are never found so they're almost
kind of like pulled into another
dimension that's sort of
hinted at
and if you read the final chapter of the
book which wasn't actually published
uh when the book was published but was
actually published later like as a short
story or like an addendum and i think it
was called the mystery of hanging rock
or something like that she does actually
strongly hint that there is a
supernatural thing going on like um like
the girls go up there and like throw
their corsets over the cliff and like
the corsets like float so it's almost
kind of like some
supernatural thing
and
when i was like researching this i
didn't realize but if you go on youtube
and you search
picnic at hanging rock i think it's the
law the lost ending
peter weir did actually shoot an ending
in which you see mrs appleyard who is
the older uh like the headmistress of
the school
um because you know in the
in the regular kind of the theatrical
cut of the movie they just have a
voiceover at the end that says you know
they found her at the base of the rock
as though she had fallen or jumped or
whatever but they don't show any of that
they did shoot a scene where you see her
actually going to the rock like in all
her morning clothes and she sees
sarah who is the character that died
like earlier on you know i mean she
jumped through the thing and fell
through the uh through the greenhouse
so again and then she crawls into a
thing in the rock and so you're meant to
assume that this rock is kind of like
a portal of some kind uh a super so
there is a supernatural explanation is
what i'm saying
but the reason i think that she left um
this last chapter out of the book and
why peter weir chose to leave that scene
out of the end of the movie
i think they liked uh
to leave it ambiguous and also
i think that not only does hanging rock
represent in the movie like a vortex or
a portal to another dimension
i think there's also kind of like
something about
it almost represents like
chaos or
um like indifferent nature is what i'm
trying to get at because there's a lot
of
dichotomy in this movie
about all the english characters who are
all very upright and very you know
they're they're scenes of like all the
girls putting their corsets on mrs
appleyard has that perfect [ __ ] hair
everyone is very very proper and
everything whereas the australian
characters uh you know and somebody
pointed out that it was the same guy who
was in wolf creek mick taylor yeah he
was really really young in this playing
albert who's kind of like a working
class australian guy so the australian
characters in the australian setting
are sort of like uh wild and chaotic
and uh it's kind of contrasted against
like these english settlers who are
there who are very very
upright so it's almost kind of like this
rock the fact that these two girls um
and this woman because one of the girls
does uh get found later on but she
doesn't remember what happens but the
two girls and the woman that don't come
back
it's implied that they never say what
happens to them but i think it's just
because it's the movie's making a
statement about
that's what life is like like the
chaotic you don't like always get
uh an answer to what like sometimes
people just vanish and you never find
out what happens to them so it's almost
kind of like
making a statement about like again like
the indifference of nature the
indifference of life just the chaotic
element to it also and i don't see a lot
of reviewers bring this up
but i do think um you know with the
whole thing with the contrast between
the very very strict upright british
characters and the more wild like
australian environment and the
australian characters
i think that there's a little bit of an
implication going on there too that
whatever chaos is going on at hanging
rock
it has a sexual component to it as well
like almost like a like a pan type of
thing like a nature spirit
because
the character of sarah the orphan
is actually uh
really into miranda one of the girls
that later disappears
and it's implied i don't know if i'm
just reading this into it but it's
implied that there's
uh a sexual tension or some kind of
sexual feeling between the two of them
to to the two girls uh which would not
have been proper during this time period
there's also
i felt like a little bit of sexual
tension between
the upright english
guy who gets obsessed with the girl's
disappearance and goes to look for them
uh michael
and the australian hunky more wild uh
working-class carriage driver guy albert
i kind of got a little bit of sexual
tension between them as well so i kind
of feel like there may be making a
statement between
you know
maybe
that this mountain or this geological
formation
representing
again wild wildness chaos so some people
might actually want that because it does
seem like miranda and the other girls as
they climb the mountain like before they
disappear they start shedding their
clothing like this you know this very
restrictive english clothing that they
have with all the stockings and the
shoes and the corsets and all the layers
and everything so they start like taking
their shoes off they start taking their
stockings off they take their corsets
off
as they're going up and they're going up
like barefoot and they almost go
willingly and you know in miranda you
find out like one of the girls that
disappears
sarah says of her of her later she knew
that she wasn't going to come back
so it's almost kind of like they went
there and like they chose that like you
know what i mean they chose to go into
the chaos or into the wildness and it's
like you never find out what happens to
them but like i said if you
read the original uh
end chapter that was cut out of the book
and
if you look a little bit because i saw
like the end
you know
the ending that they shot from the movie
that they didn't use and that's not as
clear but it the implication is that
this
place is like a vortex
of some type
um which again is implied because they
do talk a lot about
time and
you know and that kind of thing so you
know that there's some kind of like
supernatural interdimensional [ __ ] going
on but
as i said i think they wanted to leave
that unclear so that you could have more
of like a symbolic type of thing
because you can read into it a lot of
ways but like i said i'm pretty sure
that
that that rock like symbolizes
again like chaos or like in a different
universe i guess
and that's the reason that they kind of
contrasted
you know this that's why these
characters being
you know set in this time period in 1900
being very very proper english people
like you know and they're colonists
essentially like in this australian
wild that they're not really all that
comfortable with
um i think that's kind of why that
dichotomy is in there as well
uh yeah slasher friend says or a
wormhole
and uh yeah slasher fred says the
original blair witch project kind of
sets up like a true story yeah and i
kind of feel like this
it's interesting because the book did
that as
the book of this did that as well she
absolutely like the author absolutely uh
presented this as a true story and she
used real things in it like real
locations and stuff even though some
stuff you knew wasn't real because
um i was reading one thing that said you
know valentine's day of 1900 which in
the movie is portrayed as a saturday i
think but like in real life it was a
wednesday so obviously this stuff didn't
really happen
but
she kind of like made it
made it seem like a real thing and i
think later on when people asked her
because it did actually go into folklore
in australia as maybe this is something
that actually really did happen and that
she wrote a book about it um
but when she had people ask her later on
is this a true story did you base this
on a true story she said don't ask me
that question it doesn't matter you know
what i mean she because she wanted to i
guess like make a statement against
maybe like the uh you know
the whole line between fiction and
nonfiction being very porous
yeah and she just said it doesn't really
matter like you can take whatever you
want out of the story it doesn't matter
if it actually really happened or not
it's a well-made movie it looks really
good
uh it's got good cast the acting is good
it's very classical it looks very very
british
kind of period piece uh but it violated
too many of my rules all right like uh
if it doesn't pull me in in the first
five or ten minutes i'm never gonna get
pulled into it
so as
as it started to go it started to do
[ __ ] that i didn't understand and
mystery started to happen but by that
point i didn't care so i started just
kind of checking out from it kind of
like a
agatha christie type mystery weird [ __ ]
going on but
by the time i realized what kind of
movie it was i didn't care anymore
so i just started looking at my tablet
and stuff just
it's not my kind of movie but i can
understand some people this might be
they might be into this
yeah it's i mean basically it's just and
like i said i didn't even know this
until recently but they did remake it in
2018 i don't know if the remake is any
good or not
but
yeah if you don't like and actually this
movie is
was really like influential on certain
types of particularly uh sophia coppola
her movies like uh the virgin suicides
in particular like took a lot from this
uh it looks almost and even marie
antoinette to a to a lesser degree
but
um it just goes to show that this type
of movie yeah this is definitely one
that
one
if you don't like ambiguity in movies
then you know it's just going to make
you mad because the mystery is not
resolved although as i said there are
hints and you can kind of bring your own
thing to it um but you know if you like
everything very straightforward and
spelled out then no then you will not be
into this movie uh this movie is a whole
vibe and you're either gonna vibe with
it or you're not gonna vibe with it um
it looks like as i said it's set in 1900
it looks like um
it just looks like this pastoral
painting almost you know what i'm saying
and it's very like hazy and like soft
focus
and
everything is just kind of engineered to
whether it's like the sound design or
the score oh the score by uh
zamfir master of the pan flute do you
guys like remember because you mentioned
something about the music and i said
it's damn fear master of the pan flute i
was like don't you remember well then
you remember like in the 80s they had
those [ __ ] um infomercials where they
were selling his albums and stuff but
this was before
before he became kind of like a
punchline yeah what's funny is that
he throws in his title master of the
plan well i was only on the channel i
wasn't sure if you knew if you
remembered who zamfir was
that's why i added that so you would
remember today we said some fear
some fear over and over again
master of the pan flute you know and
then it's showing all the [ __ ]
yeah he laughed at me when i said
the pan
well because like i said what i just
said they have beer i didn't know if
you'd remember who that was because
sometimes you don't remember exactly
i was like yeah from the infomercials
but like i said
this came out in 1975 and this was like
way before the infomercial thing sam
fear was only famous
because of the damn infomercial you
wouldn't he bought that [ __ ] [ __ ] he
wasn't famous before that [ __ ] so if if
so he was a genius because because he
might have made like millions of dollars
from those probably did and like look
like kids people like us that were kids
at the time still remembers the fair
master of the pamphlet it goes to show
that
[ __ ] can appear out of nowhere
claiming to be fully formed a [ __ ]
master of the [ __ ] world renowned and
famous and [ __ ] nobody knows who this
dude is well he did because he did movie
scores but it's just dave famous he
became famous because of that because of
that he was known in movie circles
because he had done some movie scores
including this one
but he wanted to be worldwide facebook
just for not like you you want to be so
famous that you're like a punchline and
everybody knows who that is because
that's how you know you've arrived but
uh it's just funny that i still remember
that because i even he was the fabio of
musicians
fabio that was another [ __ ] just
appeared he made himself famous for
being famous
no he would no he was famous because he
was the uh cover model for all those
[ __ ] paintings right on the uh
that's ridiculous that's not what made
him famous what made him famous was
[ __ ] butter and artificial butter
made that [ __ ] famous that's
true he can't believe it's not butter oh
and getting hit in the face by a goose
wasn't it a goose yeah on a roller
coaster
i mean you know he did a lot of modeling
for the cover of those [ __ ] yeah he
was on man
but like i said if you're that famous
like where i assume i wasn't a big
romance novel reader um but if there was
a whole subset of like middle-aged
ladies who knew who he was they might
not have known his name but they were
like hey it's that dude again dude like
on the cover because he was on a [ __ ]
tonight i couldn't believe it his name
recognition happened when he's [ __ ]
doing butter commercials
i do remember okay
that's that's how he got name
recognition
man's work they even made him a joke on
on mystery science theater they did a
sketch where they had like the fabio kit
yeah where it came with a wig and
muffiny chest piece okay and then and
they did like a little commercial for it
where they all went fabio
like throwing their hair around yeah
oh and it had a chin too i think i think
it had a [ __ ] roman nose um i don't
think it had a nose i think it had a
chest piece and a chin and a wig yeah
and maybe that was it i can't remember i
can't remember what um what episode that
was from it was it was a mic episode so
it was like post
it was probably season six i'm sure
zamfir [ __ ] did some shows for some
rich people up in their [ __ ]
manchester and
cut a few albums but the average person
didn't know who zanfare was until but
now they do until they did that until
the 80s they they brought that [ __ ] to
the trailer park yeah everybody's like
oh that's pretty every middle-aged woman
in the [ __ ] trailer park buying a
damn double album look i'm classy classy
now well yeah yeah listen to like i said
a genius
no condor pasta
pan flute version
[ __ ] out of here
it is pretty though it's funny because i
had forgotten that zamfir had done the
music for picnic at hanging rock and
when i was like listening to it and i
was like oh my holy [ __ ] at zamfir and i
was like that is really pretty though
but see
it's easy to say it's pretty now because
we passed the time when it was like
cheesy because in the 80s because it was
an infomercial
it was like cheesy as [ __ ] but now you
can actually like appreciate it there is
other it's not all zamfir they actually
do use some like some other classical
pieces in this it's a lot of studio
musicians that play that [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah there's they're out there a lot of
them are down in central and south
america like uh
chile and and in the andes regions they
do the flutes all different kinds of
flutes so that's dudes from the [ __ ]
favelas playing that playing it on the
street
in brazil making coins i remember it you
know what i mean that yeah back in the
80s that [ __ ] was just real
common
dudes from peru with the [ __ ] woven
hats out there were playing on the
street doing pad flutes and [ __ ] yeah
yeah and [ __ ]
ocarinas and [ __ ] you know because
that's their
you know i wondered i wondered if guys
like that like in the 80s where they
pissed that like zam fear made
everything yeah
you know they're like dude what happened
to my [ __ ] you know he's like man i'm an
artiste what the [ __ ] now you're just
like making it like so you could put it
on the [ __ ] infomercial and now like
you know cletus at the [ __ ] trailer
park
and i see it and i know what it is you
cannot lie to the vanilla gorilla i know
what it is
[ __ ] okay
honky kong
it's hockey yeah
i like honky cotton
still gotta make my hockey [ __ ] shirt
yeah we gotta do that like i said i have
to make a little i need a i need to take
a picture of you that i can like
pixelate you know what i mean like a
clear enough one like you doing a donkey
kong pose that i can make
donkey kong and just put my face on it
well okay you know what i mean but you
gotta stretch it or something well nah
don't worry about it that's what i don't
worry about it i could i could do it
right just copyright the whole thing
just put donkey kong on there and just
change it to honky kong and put the [ __ ]
people don't even know what it is i
don't even know if the average person
would know what that what we were
talking about maybe they would yeah
they're probably what donkey kong is
yeah yeah i'm pretty sure everybody
knows a donkey they still know what
donkey kong is yeah even though it was
like the 80s yeah um yeah adriana says
uh payoff in this movie isn't worth it
yeah it's um i think it is i really like
i said i'm really a big fan of ambiguity
and horror not always uh you can't just
make an ambiguous horror movie and go
uh-huh but you know what i mean i think
that there's enough
clues in this uh for the implication to
become fairly clear like what the hell
is going on because like i said even if
you don't have
uh the luxury of knowing what the end of
the book was or you know that wasn't
published until later um you still
know that it's some kind of like time
displacement or some kind of like portal
or interdimensional kind of shenanigans
going on um so that is pretty clear
and like i said you know
this movie i can understand like if it
pisses some people off because they're
like well the mystery isn't resolved but
as i said the mystery not being resolved
i think is kind of like the point of the
movie because they're saying yeah like
in real life like [ __ ] like this happens
all the time there's like a mystery and
it doesn't get resolved and you just
have to like deal with it so there's
that kind of thing too adriana says that
the acting is hammy and cheesy
very british stagey that's all bbc well
interestingly though a lot of the girls
in this um they just they picked them
for how they looked rather than because
they wanted them all to look kind of
like ethereal and innocent sort of
um because that was kind of another
thing and that was another little
undercurrent and that's what i was
saying before where i think that kind of
like quote-unquote like wild sexuality
was kind of a a component of what was
going on with the whole like wildness of
whatever this hanging rock was like i
said a nature type thing so it goes back
to the french porn flick it's like well
no but well because
um casting because there was a lot of
lines in this
about uh you know one of the girls they
found or her corset was missing there
was a lot of stuff about them like
taking their clothes off uh the older
woman who also vanished missed uh mcgraw
or whatever her name was uh mccraw
um you know they saw her later and she
just had like her pantaloons on which
was very scandalous um and also there
was kind of stuff about
where where it was kind of like uh the
doctors when they found like the girl
they're always saying well she was
intact meaning she wasn't raped
uh because i feel like there was a whole
there was a whole like subtext of like
sexual violence going on like maybe they
all got spirited away and like raped to
death there was a lot of uh kind of
stuff like that sprinkled throughout
here too so that's kind of what i'm
saying that why i think that
hanging rock as you know the geological
formation because it used to be a
volcano like in real life it did and so
it represents this sort of like wildness
of nature and indifference of nature but
also kind of like sexual
liberation but also sexual violence is
in that mix as well yeah i didn't get it
yeah well like i said this is one where
every there's not you know there's
dialogue in it but
you really have to kind of listen to all
the dialogue and everything kind of like
means something you know what i'm saying
um it's that kind of movie where you
really kind of have to
pick up on a lot of clues that are not
really spelled out
and to me
i don't know that to me that makes it
creepier there's something like really
unsettling about this i really and like
i said i particularly like when they
first get to
the rock
and
that sound that the rock makes that just
weird
that kind of sound that it makes and
it's almost kind of like you know that
there's like some weird [ __ ] going on
there and they one of them say because a
lot of their watches stop like at noon
and they're talking about oh it must be
like some weird magnetic thing so that's
why i kind of think it's some kind of
weird like i don't know like ley lines
or like some weird vortex or some [ __ ]
like that i think that's kind of what
they're implying but
you know what i mean uh cheryl says this
movie is still a must-watch because it
influenced so much yeah i mean this was
again the first movie that got like an
international audience of the australian
new wave i mean peter weir
he made um [ __ ] he made somebody he made
gallipoli he made what was that one um
the year of living dangerously wasn't
mel gibson in that he made that and then
later on he made like some kind of big
he's made the truman show he made dead
poets society um so he went on like to
much greater things most of his movies
have actually been uh quite big hits
but he made one called the last wave too
like uh which an early australian film
which is also very good if you haven't
seen that i just saw that not too long
ago
um but yeah i would also recommend that
one that one actually might have come
out before
this one now that i'm thinking about it
i think shutter had it for a little
while but i don't know if it's on there
anymore
uh nostalgic top hat says the ambiguity
augments the tension and the horror yeah
see i
i get if you know if some audiences
don't like that like i said i'm not
[ __ ] on your judging or anything
like that because people like different
[ __ ] and that's fine um but to me i
think it makes it like eerier and more
unsettling that you don't
that it's not exactly spelled out to you
what's going on and that the situ and
that the mystery is not really resolved
um you know i don't know i like that
so it's it depends on like what you want
from it i guess uh danny rowling says
also deemed a valentine's day horror
film by some yeah that's that's why we
did it today i was gonna do it yesterday
but we were already doing valentine that
slasher uh because this it's not super
valentine but it does take place on
valentine's day and there is a little
bit of that like toward the beginning
um and then cheryl also says poor fabio
that must have hurt getting in the face
hitting in the face with it it was a
goose right was it a goose or a duck i
don't remember it he was on a meds i
feel like that was the 90s well not the
90s he was on a roller coaster
and
can you imagine of like all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're on a roller coaster and he
got hit like right in the face by a bird
i think it was i think it was a goose
and it broke his nose
and it's kind of sad because it's like
imagine you're famous and that happens
to you and [ __ ] like me that's like
one of the only things they remember
about you like decades later like after
that happened how much would that suck
he was lucky to get known i guess
especially back in that in the olden
days when the media only had a very
narrow bandwidth it was hard to get
known back then there wasn't
many the media was small there wasn't
many avenues
you know [ __ ] nowadays a dude like
him he would just be on instagram
yeah he would just build like an
instagram box it'd be an instagram ball
yeah cheryl said it was a goose i
thought it was right then i thought then
i questioned myself i was like wait was
it a duck no it was i'm pretty sure
um
yeah cheryl says oh it's a beautiful
location hanging rock it was probably a
more popular tourist destination after
this movie came out i wondered if it was
because i wasn't really sure i mean this
came from a novel the novel came out in
1967 and i didn't know
if the novel was popular enough to have
you know made the location really
popular it's a cool looking
place though
um and they did actually shoot it there
like i said it's a real location you
can't actually go there used to be a
volcano
uh but yeah i kind of actually wouldn't
mind
reading the book it sounds like the
movie is a pretty close adaptation i
think there was one little subplot that
they left out of the movie but i don't
think it was super important
um
but
uh it sounds like like a pretty close uh
adaptation altogether
uh let's see uh adriana says i like
spring from 2014. you know what um
i've been meaning to watch that i think
i watched like the first few minutes of
it and i said oh this looks good i'm
gonna have to like finish it and i don't
think i ever did i was actually gonna do
it
this month for
uh
folk horror but i don't know if i'm
gonna get around to it now but i think i
will eventually get around to it it is
on my list so because i hear a lot of
people talking about that one so i
definitely do want to see that
um so
yeah let's wait uh oracle says yeah the
indifferent danger of the great outdoors
yeah that's what i'm saying like the
indifference of nature i kind of feel
like that's uh what they're talking
about and then cheryl says the heavier
girl needs a punch in the face yeah she
kind of does i agree
um
yeah oracle also says otherwise known as
mother nature doesn't even care if she
kills you yeah i kind of got the feeling
that that was uh an underlying thing of
this movie
all right so
uh i guess we should probably like wrap
it up because i think like the
landscaper dude probably wants to yeah
he's gonna get in here and measure some
windows
so uh we gotta let him do his thing so
uh thanks everybody for dropping by uh
it's tuesday right okay so tomorrow
night we're doing our regular episode
this should be a fun one we're doing
uh dr kellogg and the battle creek
sanitary oh okay like all of his like
health stuff yeah yeah way half his time
that dude was yeah interestingly but
yeah it's it that'll be a fun topic yeah
uh but yes i because somebody like
mentioned it a couple weeks ago so i put
it in the poll and that one sometimes
yeah so uh that should be fun so yeah
everybody drop by tomorrow evening and
we'll be talking about that so uh yeah
have a good rest of your day you guys
and we will see you guys again tomorrow
bye